Este es solo uno de muchos ejemplos.
Ucrania ha sufrido de la propaganda y las falsas noticias rusas
desde hace ya cuatro años,
pero Rusia no es la única que lo está haciendo.
Las noticias falsas se esparcen por todo el mundo.
Todos hemos oído noticias falsas, las vemos y leemos todo el tiempo.
Pero el problema de las noticias falsas
es que no siempre sabemos qué es falso y qué es real,
pero nuestras decisiones se basan en hechos
que recibimos de la prensa y de las redes sociales.
Cuando los datos son falsos,
las decisiones son erradas.
Muchos empiezan a dudar de todo
y esto es aún más peligroso.
Se vuelven presas fáciles para los populistas en las elecciones,
o incluso toman las armas.
Las noticias falsas no son malas solo para el periodismo,
son una amenaza para la sociedad y la democracia.
Hace cuatro años, soldados sin distintivos entraron a la península de Crimea
y en el mismo momento,
los medios rusos enloquecían con noticias falsas sobre Ucrania.
Así que un grupo de periodistas, del que yo era parte,
creó un sitio web para investigar estas noticias falsas.
Lo llamamos "StopFake".
La idea era simple:
tomar una noticia, buscar pruebas de su veracidad,
como fotos, videos y otras evidencias concretas,
y si resulta ser falsa, la ponemos en nuestro sitio web.
StopFake es ahora un centro de información
que analiza propaganda en todas sus fases.
Tenemos versiones en 11 idiomas y tenemos millones de visitas.
Hemos enseñado a más de 10 000 personas cómo distinguir lo verdadero de lo falso
y hemos entrenado a verificadores de información en todo el mundo.
StopFake ha desenmascarado más de mil noticias falsas sobre Ucrania.
Hemos identificado 18 historias
creadas a través de noticias falsas.
Por ejemplo:
Ucrania es un estado fascista, un estado fallido,
un estado dirigido por una junta que llegó al poder por un golpe de estado.
Hemos demostrado que no es mal periodismo,
es un acto deliberado de desinformación.
Las noticias falsas son un arma poderosa en la guerra de la información,
pero podemos hacer algo al respecto.
Todos tenemos teléfonos inteligentes.
Cuando vemos algo interesante, a menudo es automático.
Solo damos clic y lo compartimos.
Pero, ¿cómo podemos evitar ser parte de las falsas noticias?
Primero, si es demasiado dramático,
demasiado emocional, demasiado sensacionalista,
entonces es muy probable que no sea cierto.
La verdad es aburrida, a veces.
(Risas)
La manipulación siempre es sexy,
está diseñada para cautivarnos.
Investiguen Uds. mismos.
Ese es el segundo punto, muy simple.
Revisen otros sitios.
Busquen fuentes de noticias alternativas.
Busquen nombres, direcciones, matrículas, expertos y ofertas en Google.
No crean solamente, verifiquen.
Es la única forma de frenar esta cultura de noticias falsas.
Esta guerra de información no se trata solo de noticias falsas.
Nuestra sociedad depende de la confianza:
confianza en nuestras instituciones,
en la ciencia,
confianza en nuestros líderes,
confianza en nuestros medios informativos.
Y depende de nosotros encontrar la forma de restaurar esa confianza,
porque las noticias falsas la destruyen.
Entonces, pregúntense:
¿En qué han perdido la fe?
¿Cómo se ha arruinado su confianza?
Y, ¿qué van a hacer al respecto?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)